we all live in our bubble my therapist
calls it the Lifeboat we all live in our
Lifeboat right but we're all on the same
ocean so depending on how good your
Lifeboat is you will we the storm or not
because if you're not willing to go in
there and face yourself you're not could
find anything you can live right here on
Surface man right here on Surface don't
have acid don't have AET boy that never
goes out of style does it I mean think
about it if you're going to do something
if you've chosen to do something
whatever it is easy hard if you give it
your all and you don't have asset win
lose draw get what you want don't get
what you want whatever the outcome is if
you don't have fet at least you're not
going to have to wonder oh would the
outcome have been different